bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va faire
un point et un bilan général sur la
fameuse tablette
on a beaucoup parlé tablettes d'ailleurs
je sais même pas si on peut parler de
table est tellement cet outil à de
fonctionnalités à savoir la yoga book de
lenovo
je vous l'avais expliqué il ya quelques
temps j'ai eu la chance d'être
sélectionné par les nouveaux points pour
être l'un des 50 testeurs officiels de
la yoga bout qu'on a eu un programme
durant tout l'été à partir du mois de
juin jusqu'à fin août alors la shdm est
effectivement un petit peu en retard je
suis désolé pour effectivement vous
parler de cette boucle vous la présentez
vous expliquer les différentes
fonctionnalités vous montrer ce qu'on
peut faire avec et ça bien sûr cette
objectivité bien évidemment on n'a
aucune contrainte et aucune obligation
de la part de l'est nouveau si ce n'est
d'être loyal dans nos propos donc tout
ce que j'ai dit tout ce que je continue
à dire sur cette tablette sur cet
ordinateur est complètement loyale ce
qu'ils ne connaissent pas je suis sûr je
parle deux stratégies youtube sur ma
chaîne également des produits
d'affluence des produits qui nous aident
à réussir dans votre vie digitale
d'ailleurs si vous d'avoir toujours plus
d'informations sur votre stratégie ou
sur les produits digitaux
je vous invite à vous abonner à la
chaîne est activé à cloche pour ne
manquer aucune publication alors on va
faire autour de sept lieues gamme canon
pour vouloir présenter très rapidement
le yoga book c'est quoi alors là yoga
books est effectivement book un petit
bouquin vous ouvrez votre tablette vous
avez d'une partie un écran d'une partie
une zone qui est soins clavier soit une
tablette graphique pour pouvoir dessiner
dessus vous pouvez utiliser un
ordinateur vous pouvez l'utiliser avec
cette partie qui est aimanté pour
pouvoir dessiner dessus et faire des
notes alors comme vous pouvez le voir je
fais des dessins avec mon fils je ne
suis pas graphiste donc les dessins sont
quelque peu rudimentaire
donc vous pouvez aussi la replier pour
la poser sur un support est utilisé pour
visionner des films parce que vous vous
l'utiliser comme une tablette la
refermer pour la tenir à votre main
comme une tablette c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est très pratique qui
a plein de fonctionnalités alors la
particularité de cette yoga book de les
nouveaux c'est bien évidemment ce mode
tablette graphique vous avez
cette petite palette qui est aimanté
voyez les jolis dessins monfils bientôt
quatre ans c'est vraiment bien amusé
avec vous le posez là cet est monté et
l'intérêt c'est qu'avec votre stylo ça
va reconnaître tous vos mouvements et
voulez vous verrez vos dessins vos
prises de notes s'affichait directement
ici dans le logiciel dédié alors est-ce
que sept chiots gars book de lenovo
et bien oui ou non qu'est-ce que j'en ai
pensé alors forcément syndic est très
subjectif parce que d'une je ne suis pas
graphiste
donc j'ai pas pu apprécier à fond les
qualités techniques de ce produit pour
effectivement faire des dessins utilisé
comme une tablette graphique
s'il est utilisé surtout pour faire du
traitement de texte et taper directement
aux ce que j'avais à faire faire des
recherches sur internet naviguer
regarder les séries regarder des vidéos
sur youtube
donc c'est vrai que de ce point de vue
là c'est très pratique
l'écran est plutôt pas mal si on compare
avec d'autres choses là je compare avec
un ipad alors il faut comparer ce qui
est comparable
mais d'un point de vue écran ça se tient
vraiment bien l'intérêt que c'est que
c'est très très faim vous avez un
affichage qui est sympa l'écran et d'une
bonne qualité il ya rien à dire envoyer
un coup le prenez vous le mettez comme
ça vous le mettez à la verticale
vous le mettez à l'horizontale vous en
fait sensiblement ce que vous voulez ça
c'est vraiment très pratique le côté
tablette graphique je ne vais pas en
parler parce que
ma famille nous sommes pas des artistes
mais bien évidemment je vais m'essayer
la prise de notes lorsque vous écrivez
dessus c'est vraiment très très bluffant
l'écriture est reconnue ça respecte
vraiment la zone où vous avez écrit
dessus leur île pleine marche très bien
vous avez effectivement la possibilité
d'avoir une mine avec de l'encré ou
alors d'avoir une petite jupe sur une
boule de mousse qui vous permettra de
dessiner directement sur le côté
tablette graphique pour ne pas
l'endommager donc ça fonctionne ça c'est
vraiment très bien la seule chose que
j'ai reproché à cette tablette c'est la
taille de la taille du clavier
le principal problème que vous allez
rencontrer avec le clavier c'est
qu'effectivement eh bien il faut s'y
habituer ce n'est pas évident alors moi
j'utilise habituellement un macbook pro
donc forcément les touches je les
connais là tout est plus serré plus
petit j'ai eu du mal à me faire ça ne
veut pas dire qu'on ne peut pas s'y
habituer
j'ai pas des mains énorme et j'ai pas
des très gros doigts mais j'imagine que
quelqu'un qui aura des doigts un peu
plus haut point risque de galérer un
petit peu dessus c'est à mon sens le
point négatif de ce produit par contre
un autre point qui est très sympa c'est
que vous avez deux caméras souffert des
discussions sur what's app ou autre vous
avez ici une petite caméra et vous en
avez une autre en eau
juste là il existe deux versions une
version sous android est une version sur
windows 10 pour ma part j'ai reçu la
version windows disent ça me va très
bien parce que j'ai pas pc donc ça me
fait un petit pc portable ça me fait un
second ordi je dois reconnaître que
c'est quand même plutôt pas mal parce
qu'à certaines applications qui ne
tourne pas sous mac
j'ai maintenant la chance de l'utiliser
en déplacement on est parti cet été en
vacances en sardaigne d'ailleurs si ça
vous intéresse
ça n'a rien à voir mais fait une petite
vidéo très sympa ici je les utilise et
ça m'a permis effectivement d'avoir un
outil de travail très compact facile à
prendre en main facile à mettre dans mes
bagages qui ne pèse pas très lourd
alors si je doit dresser un bilan global
un bilan général de ce produit je dois
reconnaître que je suis plutôt
impressionné par plusieurs choses par le
format le format très compact le format
poche vous le prenez vous laisser dans
une sacoche il vous suit partout alors
je vous dis
moi je ne suis pas graphiste mais j'ose
imaginer que pour des amis graphiste qui
veut le prendre des notes rapidement
vous emmener ça avec vous avec le petit
rappel vous avez toujours quelque chose
sur la main pour griffonner pour faire
un croquis ou même mois pour prendre des
notes
c'est vrai que c'est pratique c'est
rapide ça marche bien ça répond bien
donc ça c'est quelque chose de très très
positif c'est un non-sens un outil qui
va aussi bien fonctionné pour un aspect
professionnel que pour un aspect
particulier un autre point négatif sur
ce sens se produit c'est l'aspect un peu
plus fragiles je ne suis pas quelqu'un
d'extrêmement bien soigneux mais j'ai
pas non plus un barbare j'ai la mauvaise
surprise de me rendre compte que il se
réveillait assez facilement je ne sais
pas si on le voit bien ici là il est un
petit peu rayé voilà ça c'est le côté
négatif
j'ai eu également quelques rayures à
l'arrière sais pas si on les voit bien
avec le contraste mais voilà ça c'est un
petit peu un petit peu à mon avis le
souci par contre je trouve que le
système d'ouverture et bien fait ces
robustes ça marche on sent qu'à une
vraie résistance à l'ouverture le
produit est solide c'est un produit très
sérieux et vous pouvez brancher ici un
casque vous avez la possibilité de
brancher de la hdmi vous pouvez brancher
du micro usb d'un point de vue général
la yoga book de les nouveaux selon un
avis très favorable
alors après je ne sais pas si moi-même
je serais allé au magasin acheter je
n'habite pas nécessairement le besoin
jeu très heureux d'avoir pu découvrir
parce que c'est vraiment typiquement le
genre de produit je pense je serais
passé à côté parce que n'étant pas
graphiste comme je vous le disais je
n'aurais jamais utilisé ce genre d'outil
au final je suis assez content je trouve
ça bien
je trouve ça très beau pratique voilà un
petit peu mon bilan général mon bilan de
fin de test sur 7 yoga book de lenovo je
tiens à vous dire une fois de plus que
je ne suis pas payée par lenovo je n'ai
aucune obligation par rapport à ce que
je dis je ne sais pas si vous vous avez
eu de yoga bourque si vous en avez lune
si vous avez pu l'essayer
dites moi en tout cas ce que vous pensez
quelles sont vos impressions par rapport
à ce que vous avez pu voir sur toute
cette phase de test est ce que vous
trouvez ce produit plutôt intéressant
oui non est-ce que vous envisageriez de
l'acquérir
est-ce que vous dessinez est ce que vous
êtes graphiste est ce que vous avez un
talent d'illustrateur si c'est le cas
est-ce que vous pensez que cet outil
peut vous rendre service
et dites moi dans le cas contraire ce
que vous utilisez vous gérez de lire vos
commentaires je vous remercie beaucoup
d'abord regarder cette vidéo je vous
invite à vous abonner à machete pasteur
encore plus de vidéos pour elle sur
youtube et pour découvrir tous les
produits qui vous aideront à réussir sur
youtube
quant à moi je vous dis à très bientôt
si vous avez des questions vous pouvez
aussi me suivre sur twitter
@ monsieur greu et poser des questions
avec le hashtag à ce monsieur je vous
dis à très bientôt d'ici là portez vous
bien soyez sages ciao ciao
[Musique]